aujourd'hui je suis venu ici parce que
j'ai un temps libre aussi pour révéler
la vérité pour ôter moynier par rapport
à mon père est aussi on peut parler des
problèmes qui se passe dans notre pays
et bien sûr mmm période et a personne
qui va le ramener à la vie vous savez il
est ses pieds sous terre depuis deux ans
la seule chose qu'on attend c'est voilà
de reconnaître la vérité et à l'aris
petit à petit c'est bien sûr fatigant
depuis 200 d'attendre que kaka kaka se
révèle au grand jour mais on est patient
et vous savez pendant ce temps là ce
qu'on a fait au lieu de dire oui s'il
n'avait pas fait ça si lui l'avait pas
non on essaye de trouver des solutions
parce qu'on est au courant
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre dans notre
gouvernement et certains problèmes il ya
des institutions qui sont pas valorisées
il n'y a pas que la police il ya les
institutions l'école il ya pour les
informer le personnel santé toutes ces
choses là c'est pas la faute de la
population c'est la faute du
gouvernement qui valorise mal bien sûr
ces grands tensions qui sont importantes
et nous aujourd'hui on aimerait trouver
des mesures pour régler tout ça pour que
vous soyez valoriser vous policier alors
j'espère que très
raisonnable a indiqué d'autres choses ya
plein de solutions fâcheuse habitude
maintenant michel moi moi je vais je
vais te dire michel théret cueillir
souvent ici d'ailleurs cessé quoi je te
papa tue à vous de venir nous on est
très tristes pour tes neuf collègues
forcément mais il faut qu'on faut que tu
comprennes est un art mais il parle avec
le choeur ils ont perdu leur fils mais
il appert elle a perdu son père mais je
suis toujours resté monde
les neuf collègues les neuf collègues
ils sont pas morts à cause de sa mère de
l'écrivain sûr ils sont morts parce
qu'il ya une mauvaise généraux ni de
votre ministère c'est bien une
réalisation de la police britannique
sikh commencé par dire que michel faut
pas commencer à me suis aussi là neuf
dans le chai son bord
michel il et il est très triste le
japonais souffrent voilà de la calade la
souffrance qui disent ça ça il n'a pas
envie de le voir michel non plus mais
bon c'est sûr maintenant y'a pas envie
de voir t'as pas envie de voir ça me
fait pas plaisir bien sûr ici exactement
oui ça ne fait pas plaisir ça lui fait
pas plaisir ça michelle torr et il est
en train de dire aussi que la police est
dans une grande détresse alors mais
c'est ce qui est exactement ce qu'il est
dans une grande détresse mais nous on
veut aider aujourd'hui on veut proposer
ma mère en en ce moment à l'entrée des
sites créer une
une association avec certains policiers
qui sont portés volontaires pour créer
une police de proximité pour que ce
genre de drame il arrive comme je sais
que les mots mon père il va pas
ressuscité montant juste éviter que ça
se reproduise cdg mais aussi évidemment
la source du problème